let's talk about
what's happening in india it has to do
with these protests
they started late last year a new
citizenship law
offers illegal migrants the right to
become citizens of india
but it excludes muslims
more than 50 people were killed hindus
and muslims
since then delhi police have been
detaining and questioning hundreds of
people
about those protests but a report by
amnesty international accuses those same
police of taking part in the violence
so what's going on with these arrests
why is a citizenship law causing so much
anger
and why are some people worried about
what this means for india as a secular
country
[Music]
india is going through a tough time
millions of people have been infected
with kovac 19
and the economy has shrunk dramatically
and on top of that
there are a lot of unresolved issues
that date back to those protests
it's all about identity and what it
means to be indian
india has almost 1.4 billion people
about 80 percent of them are hindu
but the minorities are still huge in the
millions
muslims christians sikhs plus immigrants
from neighboring countries
[Music]
now under india's secular constitution
everyone is guaranteed equal rights
regardless of their religion
but right now a lot of people say that
equality is being threatened
that the ruling party the bjp has an
agenda to make
india a hindu nation they say the latest
sign of that
is a law passed in december called the
citizenship amendment act
the act offers a pathway to becoming an
indian citizen for migrants who arrived
before
2015 from these countries and who belong
to these religions
muslims aren't on the list but the bjp
says
it's because they're not a persecuted
minority in those three countries
the law they say is meant to help those
at risk
these uh minorities who had been living
over here they had been living
in ghettos they were living in
conditions which are not even fit for
animals to survive in why would they be
living over here
if they were not persecuted these
minorities have been persecuted in all
these three countries
but critics have been saying that if the
caa is there to offer citizenship to
persecuted minorities
there are plenty of muslim minorities in
that position
they could have considered rohingya they
are being
being attacked they are being killed
they are forgetting sri lanka
this is certainly a politics in the name
of persecution
but the caa alone isn't the problem
it's the combination of the act with a
national register of citizens that india
wants to introduce
it's basically a massive headcount so
here's the issue
to register people have to prove that
they're indian citizens
but not everyone can not everyone has
the documents
there's concern that illegal immigrants
could be granted citizenship
under the caa while muslims who are
actually from india
could be left out
here's one scenario let's say this
person was born in india where
generations of his family are from
he's muslim we'll call him abid then
there's
saranjit he came to india seven years
ago from bangladesh
he's hindu neither of them have the
documents to prove where they're from
abid can't apply for citizenship under
the caa because it doesn't mention
muslims
but surinjit stands a chance because
he's hindu
the onus would be on you to prove your
credentials
and it can lead to a major upheaval
and discard in society and muslims would
be
targeted and this goes beyond the
hypothetical
the state of assam tried to register
people and it didn't go well
nearly two million people including
muslims and hindus didn't qualify
even if they are citizens a lot of
people in assam were left off the list
because
their name was spelt differently the
government is forging ahead with the caa
and the register anyway but people
aren't just worried about it
not working many muslims say it's just
another example of injustice
in 1992 hindu nationalists destroyed the
babri mosque
there were riots and nearly 2 000 people
were killed
nationalist groups as well as bjp
leaders were linked to the violence
ten years later in gujarat fighting
between muslims and hindus
ended in a thousand people dead most of
them muslims
at the time the current prime minister
narendra modi was chief minister there
he was accused of deliberately allowing
the riots to happen
[Applause]
when the bjp was re-elected with an even
bigger mandate
in the last general election in 2019
they have carried on with the hindu
nationalist agenda
[Applause]
so it's off the back of that history
that the bjp
brought in the caa
it wasn't just muslims protesting plenty
of indians from other faiths were
against it too
people here say they no longer trust
this government and will
keep protesting until the law is
scrapped
their idea is to ratchet up the hatred
you know and suddenly
young people are just saying sorry but
we're not
buying this there were also rallies in
favor of the caa
where bjp politicians spoke to the
crowds
a man called kapil mishra issued an
ultimatum
to the people protesting against the
citizenship amendment act
and said that if they didn't clear the
roads and if
police didn't clear them then he
and his supporters would take matters
into their own hands
protesters started getting attacked then
both sides started fighting
[Applause]
hindus attacked muslims muslims fought
back
a mosque in jefra bag was attacked and
cars and homes were set on fire
muslims and hindus were killed but it
was mostly muslims
we are feeling unsafe there is no rule
of law in the country right now
the bjp and its supporters have
dismissed accusations that muslim
protesters
suffered disproportionately they also
deny using hate speech
that might have fueled violence by hindu
nationalists
any violence is it should be condemned
irrespective of who does it it's not
good for us to name our community or one
community of the other community
these protesters turned violent they
started burning the public property the
buses
and the police had to react to it but a
report by amnesty international
says some delhi police were complicit in
the violence
the police officer actually either did
not intervene
despite being present or intervened only
to disproportionately arrest or attack
anti-cea protesters
they've also been accused of actively
taking part
videos on social media seem to show
police helping hindu nationalists
collect
rocks and other images are of officers
apparently
beating muslims delhi police didn't
respond to al jazeera's requests for an
interview
after the amnesty report came out but
the government says the rights group
is biased the allegations are unfounded
completely
there are people who agreed on both
sides saying that police has
been unfair to them meanwhile delhi
police have been questioning
arresting and detaining hundreds of
people
some of them under an anti-terror law
rights activists in india say that more
than 800 muslims have been picked up
that it's being misused to crack down on
political dissent
and that police have used the pandemic
to clap down
professor apoorvant we've heard from
earlier was one of the people taken in
for questioning
they have started portraying
intellectuals as conspirators
i find the direction of of the
investigation very disturbing that there
is a conspiracy
the act of protest in itself is cause of
violence
it's all causing a lot of fear and
mistrust
we've been speaking to people out on the
streets and
they feel like they're fighting for the
very idea of india
muslims are fearful for themselves and
the others are really fearful
for the direction that the country is
going in
this is a fight for the soul of the
country what is the kind of country
india is going to be we have had 70
years of a secular brutalist
diverse nation the question is will we
remain so
it all comes back to the idea of
identity and a lot of people feeling
powerless
and excluded they want to know who gets
to be indian
and who gets to decide
[Music]
that's just a starting point for what's
happening in india as with every star
here episode
we offer the basics on a story so we can
all go off and find out more
as always don't forget to subscribe to
al jazeera wherever you're watching this
video
and i'll see you next week